los primeros cuatro términos de una
sucesión geométrica están dados y aquí
están los primeros cuatro términos de la
sucesión dice cuál es el quinto término
en la asociación y bueno como siempre te
invito a que pongas pausa al vídeo y que
lo intentes entonces bueno hagamos esto
lo único que debemos hacer es recordar
que en una asociación geométrica cada
término sucesivo es el término previo
multiplicado por algún número y a este
número le llamamos razón común entonces
bueno vamos a pensar en esto un poco
menos tres octavos es el primer término
de la serie porque el número tenemos que
multiplicar a menos tres octavos para
llegar a menos tres medios observa que
tenemos que multiplicar por un número
positivo pues estamos pasando de un
número negativo menos tres octavos a un
número negativo menos tres medios
entonces se tiene que mantener el signo
negativo y si a menos tres octavos yo lo
multiplicará por otro número negativo
como menos x menos es más
entonces se cambiara el signo así que
vamos a multiplicar
al menos tres octavos por un número
positivo para que se mantenga el signo
entonces por qué el número multiplicó a
menos tres octavos para llegar a menos
tres medios observa que tenemos que
multiplicar por cuatro pues esto es
cuatro veces esto si multiplicamos a
menos tres octavos por cuatro que sería
un negativo por un positivo eso va a ser
negativo entonces tenemos menos 12 en el
numerador y 4 es lo mismo que 4 sobre 1
entonces tenemos menos 2 en el numerador
y tenemos 8 en el denominador
- 12 sobre 8 eso es igual a menos 3
medios ahora veamos si esto se mantiene
para llegar de menos 3 medios a menos 6
observa que otra vez tenemos que
multiplicar por 4 positivo ajá menos 3
por 4 positivo eso es menos 12 en el
numerador tendríamos entonces menos 12 y
en el denominador tenemos 2 menos 12
entre 2 eso es menos 6 entonces que
vemos aquí que si se mantiene cuando
multiplicamos por 4 positivo entonces
una vez más multiplicamos por 4 y vemos
que bueno menos 6 por 4 eso es menos 24
entonces bueno vemos que si se mantiene
al multiplicar por 4 positivo ahora
respondamos a la pregunta cuál es el
quinto término de la sucesión muy bien
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar menos 24 por 4 menos 24 por
4 es menos 96 puedes ver que 4 es la
razón común para esta sucesión
geométrica y bueno solo para dejar en
claro cuál es la respuesta a la pregunta
que se nos planteó en el ejercicio cuál
es el quinto término de la sucesión es
menos 96